logan gilbert it will get the stars
really throwing the ball well this will
be a 16 start on the year 5-3 record pra
just over four 73-30 has 84 strikeouts
over just 18 walks
popped out and it'll be tight france
[Applause]
and high heat got him two down
[Applause]
he's swinging a pop-up and a shallow
right center field haniger coming in
along with celtic jarrod calls them off
and celtic will make the catch and
that's going to retire the side a one
two three top of the first inning for
the kid logan gilbert stephen mass will
make his second start against seattle
his only start came earlier this season
and he was just off the il list after he
tested for cobin and was back on the
30th of june he lost just two and two
thirds shift on against hanager and a
swing and a miss went right back to the
changeup and matt strikes him out
and the dirt gets away jp ever alert
he's there
[Applause]
there's matt's getting a borderline call
france thought it was down and in
but a match picks up his second
consecutive strikeout
that's a wild pitch in the dirt captain
kirk can't do anything with it runners
advance so crawford will get the third
on yet another wild pitch from matt's
and down to second base goes kyle seeger
zorro last night one for three and rbi
late in the ball game in that four run
bottom of the seventh inning
off the glove that'll score a run jp or
standing up one-nothing mariners secret
a third
that's a pass ball oh yeah he's gonna
catch that basket will lead things off
for the blue jays here in the top of the
second
miss tayoskar gets into one
left center field
and it is gone
number 20 on the season for tiosco
hernandez to tie it up here in the
second and this is a fastball after
gilbert missed and that is broadway
right down the middle there's that jack
and he broke it out early again so
grichik in center with springer out of
the lineup randall hitting 251 19 homers
bridgex sits on a fastball drives it to
deep left and it's gonna go second home
run of the inning for the blue jays and
they take a three to one lead so number
20 for te oscar hernandez and now number
20 for randall grichik five different
bluejays have now hit 20 or more home
runs on the season
straight up for pachette
swing and a miss struck him out second
time
slow roller type france
they get the middle portion that'll be
it
so first and third two down for
alejandro kirk
that's a fair ball down the left field
line guerrero will come in to score
dickerson's getting the wave around
third he will come in to score it's a
big two out two run double for alejandro
kirk and it is 5-1 blue jays
there's a ground ball to third aspen out
of alera for one on to first not in time
it'll be a fielder's choice for henniger
france sends one to left field left
center field and dickerson comes over
into the alley and runs it down for out
number two
two runs one earned run but they need
some link down in their bullpen
wouldn't be surprising at all to see him
up within a few days fly ball to right
to end the inning
three in the books in seattle and the
blue jays up by four
sit well here comes demo
that's a fabulous catch
great athleticism time beautifully with
the jump
well done and
just another another defensive gem by
demo a little michael jordan with the
tongue
swing and a miss he gets beshette for
the third time the time of the curveball
way outside
got it
matt strikes out toro one down
down by four now they have runners at
first and second terrence on it second
kelnick on it first base one away and
that'll bring up left fielder dylan
a moore ball to left
sunglasses down for corey dickerson to
make the catch two down
a pop-up
so matt's making a couple of good
pitches to get the last two outs in the
inning and it is indeed still 5-1 blue
jays tay oscar hernandez has homered and
singled today he went three for four
with a single double in a homer in last
night's game
and when you're hot you're hot
this one will bounce into foul territory
and hernandez is into second with a
double and now is three for three in
this game corey dickerson's got one of
those hits he's singled and scored back
in the second
and now they've got te oscar hung up and
the throw is off the glove of crawford
into shallow left hey oscar slides into
third gets back up and comes in to score
not the way you draw it up but in the
end it all works out okay for the blue
jays
and a swing and a miss strikes him out
on three pitches
curveball sent to right field t oscar
going back and he'll make the catch on
the track two down
and he gets some swinging
a much better outing for brad hand
and he's got one now bro that's the
first time in his career he's struck out
four times in a game he's just had a
tough afternoon
first batter that ramirez will face in
this game is corey dickerson who has won
for three
dickerson drives the ball to right field
and he got it all dickerson with his
first home run as a blue jay to extend
the lead it is 7-1 well we talk about
corey dickerson being a good low ball
hitter that was a perfect example of a
beautiful swing that pitch was down his
third home run of the season oscar now
he will do the honors for corey
dickerson kyle has walked fly to right
and struck out his last timeout
deep drive right field
going back down kyle seeger home run
number 26 the rbi leader has added two
more to his total with 74 and here comes
another late game rally by the mariners
got a 7-3 ball game with one out in the
eighth that'll bring up marcus simeon
now marcus simeon first pitch swinging
and drives it out for home run number 27
on the season the fourth home run of the
ball game for the blue jays the lead is
eight to three
no two
back to the mound and he's got it
and that'll do it the blue jays pick up
a win in the final game of the series in
seattle get some good pitching
they hit four home runs in the game